How do I get enough fat on a keto-like diet without dairy?
Can I eat rice and sweet potatoes on this diet?
Well, technically, if you're going completely keto, no, you can't eat rice, but I don't
think they even allow sweet potatoes on a full keto diet.
But if you're in a keto-like diet, yes, you can eat rice and you can eat some sweet potatoes.
So a keto-like diet is defined by the person who's doing the diet.
So you're not going full keto.
As far as getting fat without dairy, there's some really good recipes for coconut, oil,
bombs, and things that are out there that are actually just delicious using coconut.
If you like coconut, you have to like coconut oil, I guess, really, to go keto.
But that's some ways to do it.
I certainly would suggest that eating some rice and sweet potatoes in your person's
is asking you this question's condition would be adaptations.